there was a stark warning wasn't there
from President Obama last week that if
Britain leaves the European Union it
would be at the back of the queue the
president said for a trade deal with the
United States and now is most likely or
one of them successes Hillary Clinton
has also weighed in echoing the
president in her support for a vote to
remain well I'm John now about Penny
Morden the Defence Minister she's
backing vote and a very good morning to
Minister well leg you know this coming
from President Obama we've heard that
and now from one of his possible
successes they're not saying something
they don't believe isn't this very
damaging for your view well I think that
their comments are at best hollow at
worst
completely contradictory Obama and
Hillary aren't standing on a platform of
giving up their their sovereignty
they're not giving up their right to
make laws they're not asking for their
borders to be open all the things that
they are suggesting that that we do so I
think that we've seen now some reining
in of those comments so bomb has been on
media saying that no are security
arrangements would remain as they are so
all of the sort of the threats on that
front have proved not to be the case but
also I would ask him to be a bit more
optimistic not just about what we can
achieve as a nation but what his country
can do as well I think his State
Department has about 70,000 civil
servants in it and quite sure if we had
a female president she would be able to
multitask and I think that although they
might be pessimistic because it's taken
them 40 years to try and get to this
position on a trade agreement with the
EU the UK would be far more nimble but
on that and it's you know the heart of
the economic argument isn't it on that I
mean you would accept wouldn't you that
the President of the United States
probably knows more about you than his
Department of Commerce his Secretary of
State's and how they negotiate these
deals and how long it takes when he says
back of the queue back of the line it
might take 10 years he's not making it
up well I think this is what is so
hollow about his remarks and I'm
particularly concerned about our
national security which obviously is a
requirement for economic prosperity and
trade he will know that our relationship
with the US and particular
intelligence-sharing which is so vital
to
- not just our security but Europe's as
well it's being chipped away out by
rules coming out of Europe what is
valued will endure and what we need to
have is all our eyes on the things that
matter the operational effectiveness of
our ability to keep our citizens safe
the EU is count is counter to that and
what we need to do is to get back to
strong bilateral relationships with
Member States if we had an EU army or we
had a an EU intelligence agency it's not
going to lead to better operational
cooperation that is but done between
member states and that's what we need to
focus on do you think the mayor of
London fellow leaf campaigner of course
Boris Johnson is right that it's got
something to do with the mr. Obama's
Kenyan ancestry that he seems to have it
in for the UK no I think this is I think
that comment came from an article that
he wrote the start of an article where
he was talking about who's speculating
as to why Obama had removed the bust of
Winston Churchill from the Oval Office I
think any accusation that Boris Johnson
is somehow you know being unpleasant or
racist or or any of that is quite
frankly incredibly insulting and also as
on security you should you accept his
analysis that you know these are symbols
of a president who is lukewarm say the
least about the United Kingdom I think
that the president has been very clear
that he finds it more comfortable to
deal with large blocks of nations but
what he fails to appreciate or is not
factoring into his narrative on his
visit to the UK is that that is actually
undermining our economic prosperity and
our national security the fact that we
don't have a trade deal between the the
u.s. and the EU because it is taken so
long it's so complicated it's so
bureaucratic I think is a reason for us
to assess whether our interests are
better served taking back control of our
ability to negotiate our own trade
arrangement I think the UK would be much
more nimble I think we actually have a
greater synergy
our approach to trade and commerce with
the US than we do with many of our
continental partners and I think we
would absolutely thrive with looser ties
to the to the I kind of just ask you
about Boris Johnson I mean do you think
with this and other comments he's doing
a good job as one of the leaders of the
leave campaign representing your view
well we are out there making the
arguments we are the underdog in this
fight um but we believe what we say and
I think the public are hungry for
arguments the hungry for facts and those
we have to get out there I think the
budget price even Nigel Faraj she said
we've had some similar comments a while
back about Barack Obama even lighter for
I saying he's playing the man not the
ball on this when when talking about his
ancestry no but I don't I think that was
a that was a paragraph opening up into
an article which contained all of the
arguments about why he thinks Obama is
is wrong so a rhetorical device it was
yes it was I think that the remain
campaign are trying to focus on that to
deflect from the serious arguments about
the dangers not just what we could get
from from leaving me you but also the
dangers of staying which is that you
know as a minister in defense and my
counterpart the Minister for security we
are concerned about our ability to keep
people safe we think we would have more
powers to do that if we took back
control of our borders more scope if we
took back control of our money our
finances and our ability just on that
you're on the job you have and what you
have said about the Americans
misunderstanding of in your view of the
UK in your band particularly on the
security issue when you find it very
difficult then if the vote is to remain
in the European Union for you to stand
your post and be part of that crucial
relationship of security intelligence
sharing so much with the United States
and you believe you're telling me that
you believe they've got it wrong well I
think that most of the people that I
work with in the US are very aware of
these issues I think I would not be
doing my job if I didn't stand up and
say that I have grave concerns other
people may have different views
I'm not suggesting that will you keep
making those consents clear if the vote
is to remain in your back in collective
responsibility f we know we're in the
media are going to know you're sitting
in the department thinking I don't
believe in this I will do everything I
can to enhance our operational ability
and the operational capability of our
key partners in Europe to keep their
citizens safe I would say that qualifies
me to do this job I think that anyone
that's not prepared to do that and speak
up when they think things are going
wrong should not have that
responsibility just a lot last thought
on this story we've been reporting this
morning on Sky News that the Ministry of
Defence exemption to prosecution when it
comes to deaths and the large number of
deaths on on training exercises from the
Commons Defence Committee saying the
situation must change to allow
prosecutions yes I mean we will look at
that report very carefully we gave
evidence to it we are looking at a whole
range of things in the department
related to those issues and that's
looking at training but we're also
looking about what happens in combat and
I for one am uncomfortable that we use
MOT funds to argue against people who've
been injured against people who may be
next of kin for those that have made the
ultimate sacrifice rather than pay them
larger amounts of compensation I think
maybe we should not be in court with
those people we should just be paying
them higher amounts of compensation and
if we're going to have things like the
principle of combat immunity we ought to
be looking at doing that but clearly we
will consult on all these things well
thank you very much minister good to see
penny more than